wir sind immer zu mcdonald's gegangen
und
servus kids und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video heute wieder mit einer
neuen challenge war mit dem mars und die
rhonestadt der 3 2 1 und die challenge
lautet es ist was wie ein bietet wie
wolltest du es nennst schwanz genau ist
die ps2 nächstes die die brother
tecchannel bist du dein bruder ja ich
bin ein bruder nicht ich bin glaube ich
gerade gar nicht bei dir wie heißt du
denn bitte kann ich kann nicht nachstand
ich muss kurz mal google dass ich waffen
kriege zwei wochen krieg ist geil wochen
kriege ok schluss da ist beendet die
changing erklärte eben jens evers wenn
sich ein paar sachen sucht beginnt jetzt
würde ich sagen ab ende der schutzzeit
also keine kisten eröffnen
denn bevor du eine kiste öffnet muss zu
mir eine frage über mich bzw über unsere
brüderlichen beziehungen antworten pack
ist hab ich schon geöffnet er will
solange zu außerhalb der schutz der
anfrage waren habe ich geburtstag 24 der
fürther 1999 genau also die change da
geht einfach darum dass wir testen wie
gut ich max kenne deswegen immer bevor
ich eine kiste auf mache muss ich eine
frage von max beantworten wenn sie
falsch ist auf die kiste nicht öffnen
was aber auch schwierig dass sie immer
eine frage parat nächstes ist okay was
war der erste satz den du zu mir gesagt
hast sebastian max beißen so cool fand
damals als max auf die welt kam stand
ich einfach an seinem kinderbett und
habe zu ihm gesagt nicht hallo max
willkommen in der welt oder hallo
kleiner bruder sondern sebastian max
beißen
ich glaube hier ist vielleicht sogar
noch eine kiste muss man schauen ja erst
ein wenn du falsch beantwortet dann
darfst du nicht öffnen ja genau
wer von uns waren sie besser aus ludwig
war das erste mal alleine zusammen im
urlaub wie beide alleine also ohne
eltern ich warte
wann das jahr genau weiß ich nicht aber
es war diese ostsee freizeit ja genau
richtig das passt schon und ich haben
feiert aber immer noch keine waffe
als irgendwie waffen schwinden waffen
schwinden waffen finden ist sehr
schwierig in dieser runde
ich könnte mir natürlich schon gut
verzaubern ich habe zwei level aber wer
macht das schon ganz ehrlich kannst du
schon mal ganz entspannt eine neue frage
ausdenken und aussuchen
ich versuche derweil eine neue kiste zu
finden was ich doch relativ schwierig
gestaltet denn gesinn köln
hier ist eine gewisse genau eltern sich
rächen
wie viele jahre vor mir hast du dein
abitur was du machst es nächstes jahr
das ist so 16 ich hatte mainz 2 24 jahre
ok nein die kiste war leer
bitte schicken das letzte jahr der
nächste zu öffnen oder jena darf ja okay
ich also bis bis einem das mit was
trennt genau sonst ist es nämlich zu
schwer weil ich habe ja jetzt bisschen
den staat verdeckt und deswegen müssen
gucken dass wir noch paar kisten finden
die inhalt haben genau wie sie gut aus
immer nach ja du kannst du niemals
beantworten kann ich nie alt
wie ist mein kuscheltier hase ein
kuscheltier hase ja mit denen ich der
immer in meinem bett geschlafen hat uns
nur verwundern
ein kuscheltier haase immer in einem
bett geschlafen hat erinnerst du dich
noch an die werte sind raus ja der hat
alles in karow ding
ich weiß aber ich weiß du weißt es noch
was irgendwas dem ich es wie hase oder
per mertesacker asiaten auch genannt
aber hat auf dem richtigen oder john
cena aber hasen kannst du kannst du kann
man eigentlich gelten warum war ich habe
den immer hasi genannt aber eigentlich
ist der felix aber htz auch also
wirklich ich habe ihn immer hasi genannt
aber eigentlich was fehlt es an felix
junge klassiker es kommen der richtige
flash paket in japan immer noch keine
kiste gefunden man das wird noch live
wenn ich jetzt hier bald nicht mehr
waffen finde ich habe rüstung wie ein
vor allem boucheny leggins aber alle
andrei was spinne die das öffnen die
angreifer leer da vorne dort auch
wirklich also die balinger okay jetzt
bauen wir wieder eine frage für die
nächste ass und welche geruch in deinem
zimmer als wir das erste mal geht der
erst ein bruch in meinem zimmer a
das war diese dieser dämliche duft kopf
den ich auf der heizung hatte ja und
jetzt ich hab' noch eine frage junge das
ist richtig aus kümmern die serie noch
nie hatte ich gar nicht mehr vor mir der
flashback waren leute das ist richtig
ich hatte damals nämlich zum kleinen
tontopf auf der heizung und da hatte ich
so ein duft wann in öl drin hat die voll
vergessen man ja was junge das ist
gerade richtig cool sondern diese kinder
sehr genauen zurückzudenken tröstet mich
darüber hinweg dass ich einfach gar
keine kiste finde aber hey du hast jetzt
die nächste dach zu öffnen
nee nee ich habe einige zwischen dran ok
dann für die nächste woche keine frage
aber die frage ist ja welche
welchen job hatte dein charakter bei
flitz und der der erfolgreichste der
erfolgreichste der auf erfolgreiche
charaktere fiffis auf jeden fall
kritisch
und der war gestern nicht ja und ein
schwert jetzt wird er umgibt wie eine
wie einer von mir hieß weil ich was ist
gar nicht mehr
du hattest aber wiesen immer diese tank
klasse bin ich habe geheult ja genau das
ist ja denn was aber nicht jeder
master-thesis dentale ringmaster wir
werden neben wasser war die zauberer das
ding was was vorbild poster kommt leute
alle die flip spielen werden jetzt
tränen in den augen am beispiel war so
nice will pop bereich auch bei prostata
kam ab level 60 oder so dass wir die
weiterentwicklung
ja ich war
wir haben das früher immer merkel
genannt weil wir nicht wussten dass man
dass man die klasse mercenary ausspricht
also das war auch so eine klasse in
flyff erfahrene leute wenn es nicht
kennt ihr wird wahrscheinlich nicht von
mir reden aber es ist einfach so nice
ich dachte gestern von obst und gott
lass mir überlegt wie hast du früher die
polizei genannt als student was polizei
richtig
das ist einfach die kindheits stellen
hätte nie gedacht dass es dazu kommt
wie witzig war das bitter aber ohne witz
ja ich weiss einfach nur
doch die jackpot es ist verdammt
schwierig sie zu fragen überlegen
stimmt aber die frage mal echt alle
richtig gut bisher muss ich sagen das
waren themen die ich bisher noch gar
nicht gedacht habe oh ja ich habe noch
eine was war was war das besondere an
den abenden wo uns wo wir in berlin wo
auf uns von unserer babysitterin in
berlin aufgefasst wird
ich weiß es nicht brennen und total ich
sterbe vielleicht weiter nein ich bin
nicht gestorben aber ob das jetzt
polizeilich dauern
nein nein dieser fällt also denke ich
weiß nicht was man sich so noch mal die
besonderheit an den abenden wo wir von
uns von unserer babysitterin in berlin
aufgepasst wurde
wir sind wir zu mcdonald's gegangen und
und dann hattest du einmal hast du
diesen knopf gedrückt wurde irgendwie
auf zeigt die bestellungen fertig machen
muss sonst irgendwas gewonnen genau dann
hab ich den knopf gedrückt wo sich
innerhalb von drei minuten fertig machen
dass ich es nicht geschafft habe ich
irgendwas bekommen so classic leute die
runde war zwar ein richtiger fan aber
diese challenge war einfach zu heiß als
durch das nicht hochladen könnte man
erfährt einfach diesem video so viel
über meine kindheit das ist einfach so
cool ich muss sagen ich hatte richtig
richtig spaß heute habt ihr wissen was
über mich und meine kindheit gelernt
also dann bis zum nächsten mal haut rein
jetzt anders grund sehen wollt auf aids
kanal schreibt auch oder auf mein wollte
zog mein das könnten wir auch machen
wenn jemand kanal sehen wollt wie wir
quasi die andere seite dieses politik
machen indem ich max fragen zu seiner
kindheit und sonst zu sein in dem ich
mag's fragen zu mir stelle dann schreibt
das in die kommentare
bis dahin aber günther jauch